what up internet i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report it's july 21st 2022 we
are live streaming on rumble youtube and
blaze tv subscribe if you haven't and we
actually dropped our cold open about two
minutes ago because in the last 10
minutes or so it has come out breaking
news that president joe biden
has covered cnn breaking news right
there president joe biden who is fully
vaccinated and boosted twice has tested
positive
for covid 19. so obviously this is just
happening over the last couple minutes
our cold open was sort of a silly biden
compilation our cold close was also a
silly biden compilation so just real
quick let me just share some thoughts i
i do not know how severe it is
whether it is serious or not the guy
obviously is up there
in years i make a lot of fun of the guy
there is
obviously some health stuff going on
with him cognitively
and probably in other ways that we have
no idea
that being said as i have said many
times the president of the united states
is the pilot of the plane and the
country is the plane and i wish
that joe biden was in better shape than
joe biden is covet or not i wish that i
believed that the president of the
united states was competent and
physically and mentally up to the job
it's a it's a tough job
some of you watching this have tough
jobs but that's a real tough job right
and you got to be real sharp and you got
to be able to manage all sorts of
actually unimaginable things that could
happen all day long but we know he's not
up to the job
but that being said i wish him well i do
not want this guy to get sick i don't
even want to say
the phrase because you know what the
phrase is if biden is unable to serve as
president of the united states or if he
uh passed away or whatever it might be
you do know what happens after that
yeah we get president kamala harris we
get vice president at least temporarily
nancy pelosi
let's not forget that evil solis gavin
newsom was at the white house last week
having secret meetings with jill biden
the president's wife with ronald clayne
who is the chief of staff at the white
house with the vice president like who
knows what they know what they are
planning all of those things but i take
no pleasure in this uh look hopefully he
recovers and then we can go back to
making fun of the guy as normal because
he he needs to be made fun of right like
we have to actually make fun of these
people and call out the nonsense
that the mainstream media will not do
but just know like just the reality of
politics politics is a messy game there
are a lot of people
including probably kamala harris i just
did it there myself who are licking
their chops
they really are because they know that
the machine is done with him if you just
look at what's happened i mean look what
we've been covering over the last say
three weeks here right um the machine
has started to realize that he is
useless that whatever they needed him to
do which basically was just get the
presidency just get the dems back in
office just get rid of orange man he
accomplished that
the machine used him he used the machine
big tech hid the hunter biden thing all
of the stuff
he got in and then they didn't think it
was going to break down this quickly
they are in for a freaking disaster in
the midterms and the machine doesn't
need him anymore so
we'll see how the media reacts to this i
mean that's the other piece of course
because they're going to try to hide it
because maybe they're not fully done
with him yet i guarantee you
uh if this was trump when trump got
coveted i mean immediately it was 25th
amendment and impeachment 17 and all the
rest of it
so we shall see but joking aside i i do
not wish the president anything other
than well wishes at the moment and i
hope he recovers and i do not want
president kamala harris and i do not
want vice president nancy pelosi and and
i also just think putting aside all of
that like we just don't need more
craziness at the moment we really don't
like
there are winds that we've been talking
about here and there's a feeling like oh
we can start getting things back getting
the country right all of that stuff
modeling florida across the nation make
america florida fight for freedom again
all of those things find the right
leaders etc
so maybe we can just kind of focus and
sit on that and actually just one other
thing speaking of florida and modeling
things right i am hosting the sunshine
summit co-hosting actually with lisa
booth
i'm co-hosting the sunshine summit which
starts tomorrow night in fort lauderdale
and it's all day on saturday so lisa
booth and i will be co-hosting that
governor desantis is there all sorts of
floridian politicians and media
personalities and all that stuff and
then sunday i will be at turning point
usa
the student action summit which is in
tampa and also governor desantis will be
there so i'll have
three days of events with the governor
uh and that former guy you may remember
uh the orange man donald trump will be
there donald trump jr will be there a
whole bunch of others that turning
points asked which is really one of my
favorite events of the year so anyway so
joe biden if you're watching i i
actually do uh wish you well uh we're
going to do one story on tucker carlson
who may be running for president
possibly kinda probably not but who
knows so let's talk about it uh and then
we've got a reuben report locals
community q a uh real quick let me talk
to you guys about eugenics uh do you
want more energy to counter the negative
physical effects of aging eugenics total
t testosterone booster with testophin
will help you turn back the clock
re-energize your workouts get you better
results at the gym and help you look and
feel like the man you really want to be
eugenics totals heat contains man
boosting key ingredients like testophin
it has been validated in five clinical
studies to boost free testosterone
levels in men because eugenics total t
boosts free testosterone that the aging
process robs you'll feel stronger leaner
with more energy and drive and more
passion too your partner will notice the
difference while every product professes
quality many other products use generic
ingredients that are often far less than
clinical grade with pneugenix total tea
you get the same clinical potency levels
used in the trials and eugenics
formulation is backed by 10 years of
science and research eugenics total tea
is the number one selling testosterone
booster at gnc you can get a
complimentary bottle of nugenex total
tea when you text reuben to 231-231
text now and get a bottle
of eugenics thermo their most powerful
fat incinerator ever with key
ingredients to help you get back in
shape fast absolutely free text reuben
to two three one two three one text
reuben two three one two three one and
now back to me all right so uh coming
straight out of iowa a day or two ago uh
is this tucker carlson guy being asked
whether he would consider running for
president now tucker carlson is the
number one
host in late night cable news ever
ever okay he has unbelievable influence
it is well deserved he is a good dude he
is making sense he is basically the
number one target of mainstream media in
terms of media people right like you if
you sort of remove trump let's say or
remove what they're trying to do to
desantis now or the political people you
look at just the media people every
moment that tucker carlson spends on air
you got the media matter uh media
matters losers and all of the people
waiting for him to mispronounce a word
or pause in a weird way so they can lead
a boycott so he can't get advertisers so
that they can get rid of the show and as
i as i often say in situations like this
usually when they're trying to get rid
of tucker or when they're trying to get
rid of joe rogan or when they're trying
to get rid of me or someone else it has
nothing to do with those people right
it's the signal that you can send to the
system which is oh we took out tucker
you see how much money and influence
tucker has and we took him out that
means we can get you too so it's the
signal to the fear that they can send to
the to the viewer
fortunately they have not taken tucker
out and uh tucker was at this uh event
in iowa and he was asked whether he's
going to run in 2024
when you come back to next year's summit
will you be the fox news tv host
interviewing potential presidential
hopefuls
or will you be a presidential oh please
i got i you know i mean
you're a little flat god knows what the
future oh if you're flattered yeah you
call me a politician you know the people
i've madist at in the world
are the people who don't do their duty
and leave the vulnerable exposed
it's the dad who leaves his kids
that's the guy i just like to punch him
in the face i mean it because that's
your duty those are your children and
you left you don't care about them
that's the most basic violation there is
it's not what the enemy does to you it's
what people charged with ensuring your
welfare do to you
and i really feel that way about a lot
of leaders in the republican party i'm
sorry to say that i do
and there's a reason that republican
voters chose trump
despite all this this like giant orange
guy what we've got a perfectly good jeb
bush for you shut up and eat it
basically the average republican voter
is not represented in a meaningful way
by his or her leaders in washington and
i cannot stress that enough and i cannot
overstate how hostile that makes me
so you know i have every intention of
staying in the job that i'm blessed to
have but i'm going to keep hammering
that not because i want to weaken the
republican party no because republican
party is our only option that's it
he's good he's good you know what he's
sort of summed up in that last line is a
version of something that i often say
here which is that you don't have to be
a republican but you can't be a democrat
right when he's saying the republicans
this is the last chance we got these
guys fell often and the point is people
know they fell off and very very rarely
live up to their ideals that's how trump
got in in the first place now there is a
new republican i would say sort of being
developed right now obviously ron
desantis is the head of that but we are
seeing this sort of i will fight
republican government get off my back
republican we are not going to do
endless wars and print endless money
republican and hopefully that will stick
but the reason i want to show you that
clip is it's sort of interesting it's
like
good people and i consider tucker a good
guy and he's a family guy and i know him
off camera as well
to an extent and it's like good people
don't really want to get in the mix
for the most part and that is a
dangerous thing i mean i think that's
partly why
the media keeps politics so destructive
because the more destructive they see it
oh we're going to go after you
we're going to call you a racist or a
rapist we're going to have mobs show up
at your house and intimidate your kids
all those things all the good people who
might want to get into public service
who might want to do something good for
their community or their country they'll
just check out and i know that feeling i
know that feeling i honestly i swear to
you
when the recall was happening in
california i had a ton of people and i'm
talking major influence politics people
major money people telling me that i
should run it was before larry elder got
involved and it's like
like there was some degree of me like
this is what i do for a living i and i
like to fight which is why i fought for
the recall and all of those things but i
was like i don't know that i could
subject myself i don't know that i could
subject david to that you know we were
about to have kids we didn't have kids a
year ago and i thought you know i still
i have a family unit and i have an
extended family why would i want to put
everyone through that and that's the
danger of politics the more dirty it
gets you will only get really really
dirty people to be involved and tucker
likes to go fly fishing he likes to hang
out with his kids he he likes to to live
a life and
that's a dangerous thing that's why i
think desantis is such a sort of special
version of this he has young kids and a
great wife the first lady here casey
desantis and it takes a special person
to to be able to walk through that fire
and that's why i offer him often the
defenses that i do because i think those
good people need that extra defense so
as for tucker my guess is he he is not
going to do it i don't see a situation
that he can but you know everybody
plays their role in a certain way tucker
can offer some ground cover as someone
else walks right through it's why the
trump desantis thing i think is so
interesting because it's like man if you
guys can really figure out how to work
this thing together
take two lego pieces that don't look
like they really fit but make these
things kind of fit together and whatever
that looks like to you whether it's
trump with desantis as vp whether it's
desantis with trump doing all the
rallies and you know busting through
while uh you know blocking while
desantis goes through like whatever that
is if they could do it what a what an
incredible opportunity what an
incredible opportunity especially
knowing how weak
uh biden is and that has nothing to do
with the covid thing that was just
announced but just like the whole thing
collapsing there's an incredible
opportunity right here and tucker can do
his version of
the defense i can do my version of the
defense you watching this can do
whatever that is in your own community
hopefully voting at the very least but
there's probably more you can do like
getting on a
school board etc etc and then we will
see what happens so there are my
thoughts on that we got a ton of great
questions today and people seem to know
that i'm going off the grid and they
wanted to catch me up or they wanted me
to catch them up on some of the plans
snowbaby says how surprised would you be
if twitter imploded while you're away
how would you feel you know it's funny
well how surprised would i be if twitter
imploded i mean i don't think it will
implode like not exist when i come back
on september 1st it will still be there
my guess is this elon musk thing now is
not going to happen i don't know look i
i was a look i was very excited
obviously we covered it a ton and i
think it was good that he got involved
to get more and more people talking
about it and all of those things i think
he found out that the whole thing is
fake and manipulated i can tell you in
the two or three weeks now since the
deal has in essence fallen through um
the traction on twitter is really bad
it's like it's it's probably a 10th or a
20th of what it used to be it's no good
you know i've been jumping on truth
social which i think is doing some good
stuff it's i have way less followers but
seemingly way more engagement or at
least relative to the amount of
followers um obviously i created locals
that's where i'm doing most of my
communication with you guys i mean i
respond to people every single day there
that's the only place that that i talk
to you guys and and actually respond
myself um i think at this point if
twitter just imploded if the servers
actually exploded if the if the whole
thing just collapsed it would be good
and uh of all of the social media stuff
like it's the most toxic one it's the
one that's added the most to this
craziness and uh it's the one that
always when i come back after the month
off when i pick up my phone and i'm you
know it's just like filled with nonsense
it's the one that i'm like ah do i
really want to touch that thing press
that button so we shall see
ethan says with fatherhood fast
approaching
do you plan on spending the next three
months on paternity leave with your
husband so baby one is due august 22nd
but we do have a feeling baby one's
tracking a little bit larger a couple
days larger which counts when you're in
the the eighth month or so uh than uh
than average so we have a feeling that
baby one is coming around august 15th
um as far as mature maternity paternity
leave um
august 15th gives me two weeks before
i'm back on the grid and i'm definitely
doing my back on the grid show on
september 1st we have the the guest
officially booked i'm not going to say
who it is but it's officially booked yes
officially booked i got two thumbs up uh
you will be very happy when you hear uh
we're going to be doing that live in
miami from the local studio we're
opening up local studios here in miami
and they're being built right now and
that will be the first thing i believe
ever shot at the local studio um so i'll
have two weeks right then and there
david's going to take a little bit more
time off he's managing most of our
businesses right now and he's going to
take a little more time on that front
but my goal is to be back in studio
september 1st and then the show to just
continue as normal and then when we have
baby 2 in october
maybe i'll have to take a couple days or
something but you know fortunately we we
have great families and uh we have
resources and good people around us and
hopefully that'll allow me to to be in
here as much as possible and not miss uh
too much time
larry says what do you think about
climate change oh larry's trying to get
me canceled uh is it a real phenomenon
that is being manipulated by the various
players is it responsible for the heat
wave in europe so first off on the heat
wave in europe yes there it is hot in
europe right now you're not going to
believe this it's hot in florida today
okay um i do not believe it's related to
the heat wave in in europe or anywhere
else do i believe in climate change i
believe that the climate changes uh i
but i don't believe that
especially these people that are in
charge right now uh have any ability to
manage the climate if you think that aoc
with her green new deal
uh is going to be able to fix the water
levels and fix the co2 in the air and
any of those things like you're actually
crazy i would be shocked if aoc knows
how to tie her own shoes okay uh these
people this is a giant extraordinarily
giant craft it's why it's one of those
things that they make you so afraid to
talk about i have no i doubt actually
that media matters is watching this
right now and they will clip a thing
they often do this even when i call them
out on it they will clip a thing and see
dave rubin's a climate denier and what
they mean by that then is you're a
racist and a bigot and you hate the
earth and you want to kill children i
don't think humans can do much about it
i think we can adjust accordingly let's
say the earth is warming up a tiny bit
although for many many decades they were
telling us it's cooling but let's say it
is let's say it is um i think we can
figure out ways to work around that
figure out ways that population centers
should maybe move in different things in
different places we can think about
going to mars whole bunch of other stuff
but if you think only if we get on
electric cars and give democrats more
power and all of those things that that
will be the solution i think it's just
silly we could look more into nuclear
power and solar power obviously wind and
water power et cetera et cetera if you
want to talk about fossil fuel emissions
but i also think one of the things that
they do in the climate change discussion
is it keeps that myopic view on the
united states all the time
meaning that other countries right now
like china and india that are you know
closer to their industrial revolution
that we finished up about 100 years ago
they are polluting at crazy levels but
then you have these these
they happen to usually be rich liberals
rich white liberals for the most part
who think that if they just don't get
the plastic bag when they go to whole
foods or arowan that that is doing
anything for the environment and it's
just not true it's just not true
if you have the means you should
consider going to an electric car if
possible uh tesla obviously is making a
fantastic product i told you you have a
tesla i love it i i think it's just so
cool uh and you do feel like you're
doing a little something but then you
watch transportation secretary gay pete
saying you know we're trying to destroy
the fossil fuel industry to get everyone
on electric it's like these are just not
good people uh tasso girl says hey dave
how are you dealing with the florida
humidity especially that far south we
also moved to freedom florida from
wretched washington dc my god but we are
in north florida and the humidity is bad
i gotta tell you
it's not that bad would you guys say
it's not nearly as bad as you thought
not nearly it's not it has not been that
bad it is hot it is humid if you walk
the dog in the middle of the day you're
gonna do some dripping uh but it really
has not been that bad it's it's actually
been okay i feel like the height of the
hair has been all right i am going this
afternoon i just made an emergency uh
appointment for the uh the just get the
sides trimmed a little bit before the uh
the big sunshine summit this weekend um
but i i honestly don't think it's been
that bad and if you if you've got some
shade in your backyard and you got a fan
we just got an outdoor fan uh you're
gonna be all right so i hope europe
maybe you know northern northern i'm
guessing maybe you're in the panhandle
area something like that and maybe
that's a little more humid over there
but it's actually been okay here it's
been unusually dry that's been the main
thing in uh in miami area and uh south
florida that it's supposed to you know
every day they say oh every day from
like 2 p.m to 2 30 it storms like crazy
in the summer and that just hasn't been
happening um but it's really been okay
zionist says i do hope that while you're
off the grid you will let the community
know that your son has been born safe
and sound and maybe even favor us with a
picture uh perhaps of the bris wishing
you and david all the best as you become
parents you know i can't hear anything
about a brits and not think of the
seinfeld episode with the bris
shaky hand um
yes i will
i'm not going to do it because i really
am not touching any devices
but david or one of my team members or
someone will post something in the
locals community
that's it possibly a picture of me with
the baby maybe just a baby maybe david
and i the baby some kind of situation
involving a baby will be in the
community and that will be it for the
month just so you guys who are the core
of really what i do here and we do have
a more intimate relationship than than
the wider internet uh we will do
something there
ann says i'm kind of in a simplistic
mood tonight so one brief question
what's your favorite color
and i like blue i like blue i like a
deep blue uh i like uh i like sometimes
more of a almost like an aqua well
aqua's a little more green i suppose but
i like the blue family into the greens
and now here in florida because i'm so
lizard and iguana focused reptile focus
i've moved a little more into the greens
i like the miami marlin what would you
call that
that hat that i got what are we calling
that that's like an aqua like a teal
like a teal or an aqua so that's the
family of colors that i'm going with
mostly grammy p says hey dave i can't
imagine i'm the only mom and grandma in
the community who's wondering how clyde
is going to adjust to the new little
ones that will soon be joining you and
david the behavior of the family dog can
be unpredictable towards new babies in
the home what measures are you two
taking to prepare for clyde uh for the
two tiny new housemates great question
so i told you guys when we got down here
clyde who we got
as most of you know we got clyde the day
of the lockdowns in la they were about
to kill him at the shelter our other dog
emma who lived to the ripe old age of 16
she had just passed away a few weeks
before after a long battle with cancer
and we it was it was a tough battle we
didn't want another dog for a little
while i'm supposed to be on a book tour
for don't burn this book that's how
crazy fast these last few years have
gone so we were going to take a little
bit of a break but i saw on twitter they
were about to kill all these dogs at the
shelters because of covid it's all so
insane when you think back to it that i
just ran to the shelter i literally
grabbed clyde i almost pushed myself
through the door i'm not kidding grabbed
him they were about to put him down it
was signed already that he was going to
go be put down that day he's living the
good life here anyway he's a boxer part
pit he's got a crazy amount of energy we
got him here to florida because of the
lizards and the peacocks and the iguanas
and the snakes he's been a little nutty
but we have been getting him retrained
here and he's been would you guys say
he's been way better i don't wanna
yeah he's been way better way better
we've had a ton of workers in our house
he's all good
barking's way less he's not jumping on
people anymore i've told you the story
about how the last time that bob saggett
my good friend miss bob the last time
that bob came to my house in la bob
didn't love dogs and i said bob clyde
jumps and he's a boxer and boxer's punch
bob's like i don't worry about it bob
opens the door clyde runs up to him
punches him in the nuts bob's on the
floor he looks at clyde then he looks at
me and he goes i hate that [ __ ] dog
anyway
we saved three training sessions
for when the babies are here so the
trainer will come back
help us acclimate clyde to the dog and
also we've been we have a couple baby
clothes around right now so that we're
trying to make sure he doesn't grab them
but i think without the scent of a baby
it's a little more complex complex
perhaps so we're working on it but i
appreciate the question naomi says do
you think it will be more difficult to
stay off the grid while staying home
versus the other years when you went on
a different when you went to a different
location yeah you know the other years
we've been able to to bounce around we
did bora bora twice which was incredible
like over the water middle and nowhere
literally i would just stare at the end
of the earth for hours a day i kid you
not like i didn't talk to anybody it was
just wonderful sometimes it would be it
would be like 6 p.m we'd be going to
dinner we'd be like i said six words
today like barely spoke
for over the course of two weeks it was
just wonderful yeah this year we're not
going anywhere we may try like
august first through 3rd
to do something on the other coast of
florida but
yeah it's going to be a little bit
different but as i said we're doing a
lot of work around the house and it's
just winding down
probably in the next day or two and
it'll be nice to be here with the house
settled and everything and we're getting
the
oh well actually i'm looking at the next
question i was about to jump into it
rimfire says how's the baby's room
coming along so yeah we're getting the
nursery
in order and you know we have stuff to
do here so this is going to be a little
bit more of what i guess they call
nesting
god i've become domesticated and
middle-aged jesus
talley says people who follow you know
you're originally from new york i know
you say there's nothing about california
you miss now that you live in florida
but is there anything about new york
that you wish could make its way to
florida great question so there is
nothing i miss about california
absolutely nothing nothing not a zip
nothing
new york i do miss some stuff
you know i miss a little bit of the new
york attitude i really do i grew up
around new york when it was new york i
grew up i was born in brooklyn i grew up
in long island
lived in manhattan my whole life that
rhythm of new yorkers loud new yorkers
people always talking and arguing and
laughing
when when that was good there was
something so amazing to that and it got
exported all across america and i think
we need a little bit more of that the
couple times that i've been back to new
york city uh during kovid or since kovid
um you see some degree of it you know
you still see some guys that are the
workers in the city and they're still
loud and you know that jersey feel that
sopranos feel that thing i miss i miss
new york pizza that's for sure i know mr
01 is good i know i know it's just fine
here in miami but it is not like new
york city true pizza i miss new york
city or brooklyn or long island bagels
they say it's the water um
so i guess but it's mostly the feeling a
little bit of that feeling of of new
york and then the thing about new york
that was so special of course is that
new york became the it was really the
the genesis of what america is you know
the idea of ellis island and all of
these people you know your grandparents
most likely my grandparents who or
great-grandparents whatever it might be
who came here and they all mixed
together
lower east side brooklyn
wherever it was and it didn't matter if
they were irish or italian or black or
jews or jamaican or whatever they all
figured it out maybe they all lived on
different blocks in one neighborhood but
it was like they weren't warring with
each other it was what america was and
is about and we got to get back to a
little bit of that uh ceceto says have
you and david decided on your dad's
names yes we do know what we want the
children to call us i don't want to
announce it just yet but they will not
be both calling us dad there will be two
different names it's already very
confusing around here with dave and
david and also i will say that the
children will not be named david it's
enough of this already it's enough it's
enough tony says any lifelong goals or
bucket list items that you finally cross
off since moving to florida coming from
cali i've always wanted to get scuba
certified and i'm doing that next week
well that is awesome uh and
congratulations on leaving california
for the free state of florida you know
what i have this is not like a bucket
list thing because i've done it before
but just something i have not done yet
since i have not gone fishing since i've
been in florida yet i want to get on
a big ass boat and i want to go into the
deep blue sea
and i want to do some serious fishing
and i just we haven't had time yet
actually maybe that's something i can do
first couple days of august um and just
get out there you guys want to go
fishing you want to go michael's afraid
of the boats you fear you puke he gave
me the puke signal all right you're off
the boat you wanna all right phoenix is
on
yeah little of this all right you're on
the boat uh yeah that's that's not a
that's not really like bucket list level
but i just want i love fishing i love
fishing and i just haven't been able to
because it's been so crazy here kelly
says what are your thoughts about
possible reasons that some kids make it
through college without coming liberal
and others don't i have friends whose
kids went in as conservatives and came
out as liberals
i get there are some liberal professors
but i feel like there has to be more
than that yeah i mean social pressures
man
they're deep and and that's why the
culture thing when we talk about the
culture war
and how it's connected to the political
war and i think what the left figured
out
is that if you win the culture war if
all of the tv shows that they see are
sort of pushing them towards leftism if
all of the news is default pushing them
towards leftism if everything that is
around them
is sort of through that that very
silly lens of like democrat good
republican mean you know democrats care
about poor people republicans care about
money all of these things it's like none
of it's true but the entire if you just
think about it as just like a river the
whole river is going this way and it's
it's a river of bs but it's going and
then everyone kind of jumps in and then
you're just taken by that thing but a
few people
are able to jump out of it somehow i got
out of it hopefully if you're talking
about your own kids hopefully they'll
get out of it too
i would be remiss if i didn't say that i
don't think the fear is really that they
will come out
liberal because of course progressivism
and leftism is actually quite illiberal
it's not that you don't want them to be
somewhat open-minded or
in touch with actual liberalism which is
about equality and limited government
and laissez-faire economics you don't
want them to come out bananas leftist
but the entire thing the entire thing
you know every headline that they see
all their professors you know professors
are usually people who can talk but
cannot do so what a great place to go to
a university where you don't have to
accomplish anything you can just
indoctrinate so
i think it's also a little bit way kids
are wired you're why people are social
creatures so you're wired to like oh
it's sort of cool these cool people but
then as you get older and i think this
is it it's why you know the famous
saying you know if you're not liberal in
your 20s you have no heart if you're not
conservative in your 30s and beyond you
have no brain it's like
it when you're young it's like oh the
system should just work and we should
all just be nice and then you get older
and you realize well but what if the
system doesn't really work and what if
people aren't really nice and it's
actually about how you figure out your
[ __ ] and respond to the world
i think that's uh probably why so many
kids are indoctrinated and it's our job
is saying people to unindoctrinate
uh phil says dave what's your take on
russell brand i think you too could have
an interesting conversation have you
thought about reaching out i don't know
that i'm allowed to say this but
yeah don't tell anybody uh
i will be interviewing russell brand
let's just say september some stuff's
happening in september who you know what
am i what am i saying here uh i like
russell brand a lot you know he's he's
definitely on his way as far as i can
tell from the clips that i've seen where
he was he was definitely a far far lefty
you may remember a couple years ago he
had a big debate with candace owens and
she kind of smacked him around a bit but
he sat there and took it and i know a
little something about that from my
interview with larry elder years ago and
he seems to be getting in real time
where where that ends up who knows but
it's very obvious to me he's fighting to
find something true he's seeing through
a lot of the [ __ ] he's reeling that
realizing that the emperor has no
clothes he's looking behind the curtain
and going ah it's just an old guy back
there not much of a of a wizard actually
so i like him a lot and uh did i say
something about september i don't
remember
amy says what's the best characteristic
your parents fostered in you that you
try to foster in your own children
well i suspect
that it's something around i am trying
to do what is right
i'm trying
you know i'm trying to fight for a world
i guess what i've done more than
anything else over these last couple
years is i've tried to fight for a world
that would be better than the current
world and i guess that has a little
something to do with the way you would
want to raise kids like you put them
into this world and sometimes depending
on when they're born and where they're
born
it's a good world and a just world in a
fair world
but usually it's an unjust world in an
unfair world and a very bad world you
know but it's easy to be bad that's why
badness spreads it's harder to be good
so i think my parents somehow got
something across to me over the years of
like hey you're here you got one shot
see what you can do
and i think i've done that remotely well
especially over the last couple years
i'm not i had probably 20 years where i
did not do it well uh but the last
couple years i think i've really done it
well and of course i i credit uh jordan
peterson for that but i but it was just
going through a lot of the mire in the
muck of life to get on the other side um
so i hope i would i would instill that
in my kids that uh
you know you
here you are
you know these kids these kids i know
these kids are going to be born into a
good family i know these kids are going
to have some advantages and and know
that there's a roof over them and have
food and all those things but then i
have to be able to teach them something
about values i have to be able to teach
them something about family we have to
be able to do those things and then say
to them
okay get going let's see what you could
do and that you just hope that they like
you enough to want to keep you on the
ride throughout that so that will be my
challenge i'll let you know in about 20
years how it goes
if you want to submit questions when we
do these community q and a's which next
week will be our last one for the summer
reubenreport.locals.com uh my interview
with ron desantis is press secretary
from our live reuben report in miami
christina pusha that is uh it's out
today it's out today well how about that
uh as i hinted maybe something
interesting is going to happen in
september related to some a certain
somebody and on september 1st i am
officially back on the grid with another
certain somebody different guy or gal
don't want to say too much and i'm not a
biologist
and uh on that note we're not going to
do a cold close today because
we had something about biden but
we're being nice around here on this
thursday in light of the covid situation
so anyway i hope you have a great day
everybody uh we are back with a panel
tomorrow and then last uh it's my last
week on the grid next week then i
disappear have a kid come back we see
what happens so uh have a great day see
you tomorrow
you